I originally did not want to watch this  movie because I didn't want to be  depressed does it accomplish this yes  does it have flaws short occasionally  pretentious a little too long overly  sentimental but with strong performances  from Hugh Jackman and Hathaway and the  rest of the cast excluding Russell Crowe  singing the film does succeed the  production design is beautiful the  cinematography sweeps you off your feet  the music is powerful the after seeing  live on camera adds to the music  strength with director tom hooper's  risk-taking direction leymah sera is a  heartbreaking overwhelming moving  musical picture overall I'd say this  film got it right